hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a race or RNA seek
choosing the right tools for the job I
am sooo family roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab roots of a
leading social media site for scientific
professional and sponsors biometrics fo
metrics is a leader in genomic analysis
affymetrix develops and provides
innovative technologies that enables
multiplex and parallel analysis of
biological systems at the cell protein
and gene level facilitating the rapid
translation of results into biology for
a better world their extensive portfolio
of translational and clinical solutions
enable scientists and clinicians to
rapidly translate their research into
understanding underlying disease
mechanisms identifying biomarkers for
personalized medicine creating novel
molecular diagnostic tests and improving
genetic marker assisted breeding
programs in agriculture for human health
and wellness for more information please
visit www com before we start there are
few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many
questions as we can and will follow up
with you if you have time for today one
a better look you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or use the Q&A button will
make sure we'll resolve any issues now
let's get right to today's speakers
we're proud to welcome dr. sridhar
shetar and document polar dr. sridhar
cheetara received a bachelor's degree in
pharmacy from Bombay University India a
PhD and medicinal chemistry from West
Virginia University and an MBA and new
venture development from the University
at Albany he did his postdoctoral
training in enzymology pharmacology at
the Purdue
University of pharmacology following
which he briefly worked at Mile metrics
mometrix therapeutics properties he is
currently a research associate professor
in the department of biomedical sciences
at the university at albany's new school
of health he also directs the microarray
and high-throughput DNA sequencing core
at the center for functional genomics
his research interests include
epigenetics high-throughput screening
technologies and drug discovery he's
also an active member of the association
of biomolecular facilities and serves on
various a b RF research groups that
focus on studies of nucleic acids
genomics and flow cytometry on dr. IAM
gerkin polar is an assistant research
professor at the department of pathology
and laboratory medicine at indiana
university school of medicine her
research interests are centered on the
identification and characterization of
novel prognostic and therapeutic targets
and breast cancer and thymic cancer she
has approximately 50 publications mainly
in the field of cancer biology for
specific expertise in the development of
novel therapeutic agents such as
targeting AF a pH a 2 receptor tyrosine
kinase protein kinase C beta anti
tubulin and torque 12 in colon breast
cancer and thymic melaleuca sees her
lamb developed a characterized a novel
human thigh a moment model designated as
I you tab one which was derived from a
patient with the stage to thigh or mom
her current research uses
next-generation sequencing micro arrays
and computational tools to understand
the transcriptional regulation by
non-coding RNAs and alternative splicing
that contribute to er-positive
recurrence / mustafa statuses i will now
turn it over to dr. treat our for his
presentation enough time guys
and see the cheater I direct the
hydrogen omics lab at the center of a
function genomics erection in Albany you
know my lab we done both microarrays and
next-gen sequencing and it's very often
that people come to me and saying I want
to do sequencing when my first question
is why and you know the answers that I
get prompt me to actually you know come
and give this talk because lately RNA
sequencing has become such a popular
thing that it's more become a fad but do
you really need to do RNA sequencing and
these are some of the things that one
needs to think about because just
because it's a new new technology
doesn't mean it's the best technology
for your experiment so I hope to lead
you through some of the questions that
you need to think about as you design
your own experiments so when you're
designing when you during during the
process of experimental design the
questions you need to ask or is my gene
on well-characterized am i doing human
mouth drosophila non-model genomes or is
it a novel genome that is not it
characterized the reason you want to do
that is because the arrays are designed
based on the information that's in the
genome see the genomes known the probes
can be made if the genomes are known
well the crops you can design the probes
am i interested in novel gene isoforms
you know is it is it that I'm just
interested in simple gene expression
experiments or am I looking for more
rare isoforms or for things like
alternative splicing gene fusions do I
care about high expressing transcripts
or low expressing transcripts the reason
why you need to think about that is
because if you have a high expressing
transcript you could saturate your
signal on your microarrays so this in a
micro risk as compared to sequencing
have a little bit of dynamic range and
that's something to consider an
important thing to think about is do i
do have the biometric skills of the
support you know if I can do it myself
do I have had the adequate support for
bioinformatics the array technology has
matured enough that there are free tools
and other commercial software available
then one can you know in a matter of
hours get to at least a very simple gene
list that you can design and think about
your the biology of your system with
sequencing data it's not quite so there
are so it's still immature there are
lots of algorithms that you can choose
from you need the computing power you
need the you need the expertise to do it
not everybody has that kind of support
or currently another important thing is
with any experiment for that matter how
much money do I have you have to look at
your experimental budget when you're
doing any experiment you know as much as
people would like to say that RNA seek
is just as much as X you know it's it's
cheap and it costs just as much as a
microarray I beg to differ because if
you all things considered you have to
think about not only the region coster
to look at the label you have to look at
the time because time is money all the
way from when you submit a sample to you
have analyzed data which means your
cervix listen how soon do I need this
data you know most it's most often than
not that that p is come to the core lab
and say you know i have a grant that i'm
thinking of submitting in you know next
month and would be possible to get this
piece of data because i want to put that
in my grand but there is it's it's
doable sequencing not so much do i need
absolute quantification microarrays are
relative quantification technology
you're always comparing the wishes be so
it doesn't micro range do not give the
optional quantification see if you do
need absolute quantification you know
you may have to take a look at some of
the other options so let's talk about
sequencing when you're talking about
sequencing there are you know you could
basically break it up into three major
classes targeted sequencing which in a
way is like really looking a small
subset of the genome typically one would
use targeted sequencing for
pathway or disease profiling for example
the implicit panel so you're running a
few gene transcripts and you know doing
the more and all words you're looking
for copy number changes or transcript
expression but happy but on a small
limited subset in the way you could
think of it as doing a qpcr or a qpcr
microwave for example like where you
have a tee jeans or so and you're just
looking at it across different samples
the more typical sequencing that people
do or a shallow sequencing which is
anywhere from 25 to 75 million reads per
sample until people tend to use this for
RNA see people then use this for
determining splice it splicing or splice
Junction identification but is that the
the most appropriate technology I don't
think so what if you're doing if you're
looking at alternative splicing you
really need more coverage and so you
really need to do deep sequencing which
is more like in a more than 100 million
bits per sample and that adds to the
value of the cost of your experiment you
know in the last 45 years I've been
there more than one paper that I can
list with say an RNA seek is far
superior to raise and people publish
data showing the comparison between RNA
seek data and microarray data and here's
one example from last year or a couple
of years ago you know and the disc the I
didn't know that the conclusion was in
microwave studies these two isoforms of
our or gamma or indistinguishable
because the to probe sets hybridize at
the exxon regions that are more common
for both isoforms however RNA seek
destroy showed that the specific
expression of our ha no war drama but
gamma t but not hot over gamma in ccr
cd4 t-cells
this is just one example but if you look
at the data you will see that grab this
is what this is this is a region that
they point out okay if you look at the
there you go if you look at the
experimental conditions they have
different time points you've done
duplicates and they've used alumina hi-c
2002 time in a 50 base prepared in reeds
and they've compared to the human you
won 33 plus to worry now is that the
right comparison to make well if the
Rays are only designed for three prime
end of the gene you're not going to be
probing the rest of the sequence right
so when you look most of the studies
that are that are published in a breed
the Agilent or Haslem to raise or the
genechip erase they simply focus on 23
privateer the three prime IBT race which
means you're looking at about 600 bass
players in the three prime end of the
gene sequencing doesn't care with your
three prime end of the gene so you're
actually floating the entire transcript
so now that is an act is an apples to
oranges comparison right instead of
doing that what you need to look at is
you need to look at comparison with an
array like a genus theory or an X
honesty a day where you actually have
probes that are all across the
transcript there's a few papers that do
that and so if you're going to compare
the three primary meteorite or anything
of course are any sick performs better
recently in recent years you have after
met Alexis come out with the
transcriptome arrays we started out with
the human transcript of 1.2 raised in
the current version is the two pointer
is and you as you can see you know in
the transcript errbody actually has
probes on all the exons and the
intergenic regions and the intronic
regions of the genome so you have a lot
more regions that are being probed all
across the transcript and in the three
prime utr alpha prime UTR which are
important for regulation this came out
of Ron Davis's group you know as part of
the blue grant this was the first
version of the transcriptome array that
was generated and if you look at this
paper you'll find out a good thing you
find that they found that the human
transcriptome array actually had better
data than RNA seek so when you when
people taste you know yes you talk to
people say oh RNA seek is better because
our microwaves are all technology it's
unbiased attentional now a transcriptome
he has microarrays a role but that
doesn't mean they're obsolete unbiased
addiction of novel transcript sure yes
RNA seek doesn't care about the genome
because you're trying to identify the
genome however when you get RNA seek
data you still have to compare it to
some reference genome unless you you're
doing it de novo so there's a dis an
issue there yes RNA seek has broader
dynamic range increased specificity and
sincerity is not necessarily the case
depends on the protocol that is used
whether you're looking at poly a in
Richmond but you're looking at total RNA
you get different results in fact the a
PRF actually did I did a comparative
analysis last year and it's an ongoing
study where they have taken the same
sample and put it on different
instruments do it in different compared
poly a versus total RNA and the results
are interesting to say the least and I
would recommend that everybody looks at
those papers before they make a choice
to say you know RNA seek is better than
microarrays now is already seek does
already seek actually give is it better
in detecting where and low abundance
transcript and that is something that
needs to be questioned as well because
it all depends on the number of reads
you have user-friendly data analysis
tools well it's getting better but it's
not there yet and yes more reviewers and
have
commented on Grant saying that you
should be doing already sick and not
micro raised but in recent years the
review panels have been you know a
little bit more reasonable in their
arguments in fact meant I know when I
said on review panels and I mean people
somebody says okay we should be doing
microarrays or not they should be doing
or any see my question in the panel is
why and most times you don't have an
answer and so there goes that argument
you know so I wish they would be
listening to this webinar is something
you learned here so she the in a few you
know about ten years ago the FDA came
out with an Emmy QC study when they took
the is struck in a samples a and B which
is sample a was stratagene Universal
reference are only an ambulance and
sample B was an ambulance human brain
reference already and they combine them
in different combinations so Sam Sam
could see was a 25 to 75 1321 mixture of
A to B and SAP 2d was a 123 mixture of
Italy so and then they put these up
different my career's different
platforms and written evaluation a
logical sequence for that set of
experiments was doing it with the RNA
seek technology and indeed that's what
they ended up doing is they took the
same bbq's ABCD samples and tried
different library prep kids put them on
different machines indoor did a
comparison and all this is published in
the nature by take our issue actually
this issue has both the CQC study from
the FDA as well as the aviator study and
it's it sort of a Bible in a way to look
at the dr NAC technology so you know
that delving too much into it I mean you
have these four samples ABCD where C is
a three to one mention of A to B and D
is at one two three mixture of a to be
if you make libraries of it to make what
for in a quadruplicate for applicants of
the same sample and you're combining all
16 samples in one pool and run them on
16 lanes to to flow cells and you repeat
this over six different sites so you can
look at inter-site availability and
intersect readability so this is good
experimental design so you get a lot of
data 23 billion map reads you know all
the way down to 15 million for a library
so what did they find well if you were
to plot what this graph gives you the y
axis you have percentage coefficient of
gradients within a site ok versus the
weeds per million so on the first metal
you have 15 million reach which would be
about 1 16th off i see claim this is one
II followed by 18 of I sickly and all
the way down to one or two high sequence
so you're going anywhere from 15 million
reads per sample should one and 80
million reach percent what you also see
in this graph is a red red line in
grabber over here and that is the data
coming from a human transcriptome Murray
okay so you can see that the coefficient
of variance across the array is very
small whereas in 15 million weeds you
gotta but 75% serie and that line goes
down as you as you go from 15 million
reads 240 million four hundred eighty
million brains now this is the gene
level okay and it isn't about this is
about one high C claim for example how
many people put one types in 11 sample
and I see claim very few and when you
really were too high ceilings or one
hopeful you know one fourth of a flows
hi-c flow so for example that's when the
data between the RNA seek and hga arrays
seem to be compatible if you go at the
exxon level it's even worse I mean look
at look at the percentage
variation that you see in me when you
look at 160 a sample that takes a one
sixteenth of high ceiling so this is
where the you know you're actually
comparing apples to apples you're
looking at a radiation within these
technology and comparing the radiation
between I if you really want it to
compare an HT a data which is the data
you should compare because these are
raised actually pro for the entire
transcript including the intergenic
regions including the three prime UTR
safai plug appears to sequencing you
need about you know one HD HD a is more
equivalent to two lanes on a high C so
when people say easier detection of rare
and low point and transcripts and
sequencing and sequencing coverage that
can be easily increased to detect the
rare transcript single cells weakly
expressed genes I ask at what cost are
you willing to do to lengths per sample
because that's the only way you can
actually get good data sure you'll get
data at fifty million reads but you're
not getting all the data you should be
saying and you could be getting more
data just by running a simple microarray
experiment instead and you know people
need to also think about with you they
want gene coverage versus X on coverage
a 10x gene coverage is not the same as a
10 X X on coverage so if you're looking
for simple gene expression in terms of
microarrays if people have used gene st
arrays vs transcriptome or x onyx st
erase this is the comparison you would
look at and so genius cherries has
probes across the transcript but not
enough on every X on to make splicing
calls but the Exxon or the transcript
number is due and similarly you know if
you want 10 XX on coverage which is what
you would need to determine splicing
then you need a lot more read reads from
your samples and you probably should be
putting in a one-sample on two lanes or
at least one name
together otherwise you just seeing the
tip of the iceberg so here's a red
Jensen at Virginia Tech actually came up
with this model where since we know the
composition of sample see in sample d in
our seq see study we can convert that
into linear equation so y is equal to y
equal to MX plus B and innocence your ex
is a ratio sample beat the sample in why
is the ratio of casar pulsate to sample
a and if you plot X versus Y all the
genes regardless of their abundance
would give you a line with an intercept
a y-intercept 2.75 the slope of point
two five and the better line with a
better technology so if you look at this
if you apply that to the data that we
found with all the way from you know one
sixteenth of your name to four lanes for
example you will see that there's a you
know most of them seem to fit if you
look at the right-hand panels on each of
these if you look at the right-hand
panels and most of them seem to fit a
good give you a nice line but if you
look down where we talked about the
intersecting point in 75 and the sloping
point kill you'll see the noise in
disparate data gets better as you
increase and get more reads per lane and
it's not until you reach two names or
four lanes that you actually get a nice
linear plot the it's ta-da however seems
to give you a pretty good data now each
t-day that was a lot cheaper to obtain
as compact or any see an inert at the
depth of using two lanes / to sample I
mean as two lanes per sample or four
sample the HD data is quicker but and
the reason I say in 60 I'll explain that
later when you compare the HTA to the
RNA seek again here when you plotting
error versus the number of lanes it
reiterates the same thing I mean you see
more variation between the individual
RNA seek experience experiments and it's
not until you get up to approach two
lanes that the data starts get becoming
more comparable the other thing that one
needs to look at is the excuse me wrong
be so here's an example of a gene where
the typical or any seek experiment your
you have to take your reads in compare
it to some genome some reference genome
usually people tend to stick to refseq
and here's an example where you see that
this particular gene has three isoforms
that are listed in the FC and there's a
whole bunch more in a 12 additional more
transcripts which are not in refseq but
if you use ensemble or vega or some of
the other databases you will find them
the exterior however takes the data from
all these databases when it's designing
the probes so the odds of finding any of
the transcripts five six seven eight or
higher with the HT ery than we did RNA
seek data so transcriptome areas contain
Propst it's designed using multiple
databases that was the HTA rate and
happy now has the interior is for the
mouse transcriptome as well as the art
RT arrays for the rat transcriptomes and
they also have probe sets that cover
genes transcript exons intergenic
regions which correlated which are
annotated for link or any long
non-coding RNA pseudo ironies super
genes and rival ribosomal RNA here is an
example of a gene in the from using the
MTA array and as you can see there's a
lot more probes that cover all the Exxon
and the integer even intergenic regions
of this of this particular gene or in
this particular transcript
will allow you to identify all possible
expressed isoforms tough to do that with
the RNA see data unless you take you
through all the separate all the
databases separately now the analysis of
this of microarray data is also easy
because a fee has come out but as a free
software called transcript analysis
console which is like I said it's free
you can start using it without a lot of
training in fact just a couple of days
ago I had I could register in the lab
but I said you don't go download the
software and he can came back to me with
data I didn't have to teach him anything
it was very intuitive just clicking a
few buttons and you could have the data
so you know going from your rifle from
from your sample to raw data takes about
a couple of days for the protocol once
you have yourself files analysis of it
takes just a few hours of course if you
if you want to look at the biology and
look at pathways and all because you
could keep delving into it but that's
the same with our initiative but if i
can get analized gene list differential
expression with alternative splicing in
a few hours i can certainly try and
include Charles data and a graph that
I'm putting in a couple of days it's a
time to achieve this data is crucial and
the software is nice in the fact that
gives you the gene list it gives you the
plots and volcano plots you can do some
pathways or pathway analysis you can
also do splicing analysis and best of
all it's free what you can also do with
this is a free has micro RNA arrays LP
has snip erase you can import all that
data in here and do comparisons and you
can correlation between and here's an
example where we can coordinate micro
RNA data with the transcriptome array
data and you can download into the
biology right again all this can be done
by anybody without a lot of training
so the bottom line why should it use it
already because it's easy to use the
protocols used total RNA for whether
you're doing mr nick transcriptome
arrays or micro XP arrays you can just
deal with total learning if you instead
in rna-seq have to think about do I need
em already or poly a selected irony or
do I need total RNA and where I'm doing
a diaper reduction the moment you to a
diaper reduction there's all kinds of
variations it variabilities that one
introduces you need a lot more sample to
start with because more than 95 version
of a total RNA is going to be ribosomal
RNA in the case of the microwave doesn't
affect it because you have you know the
probes are not going to be effective by
ribosomal RNA that are on the analysis
software is quick and easy and it's free
now why would I choose already seek well
the dynamic range I if I want absolute
quantification than microwaves will not
give me absolute quantification that's
where I would need to use RNA see if I'm
dealing with a genome like xena piss for
example which is incomplete or I'm
characterized and probably need to use
RNA see as a better approach in there
are a race but once the genome is known
an array can be designed right so going
forward as more people to RNA seek and
identify the genomes and the
transcriptome theories will get better
designed and give you more options if
you're if you're looking for meta
transcriptomics or host-pathogen
interactions we looking at both the the
bacteria and the human cell your viruses
and human cells are NAC doesn't care
what genome you're looking at you can
get all the data and then mask the human
genome or the host genome and look for
the pathogen or vice versa the arrays
are not even into one genome per area
usually so that's a that's where again I
would have broke with the RNA seek
option and as Steve Jobs said you know
the overall point is that new technology
will not necessarily replace old
technology but will date it
eventually it will replace it you know
when people will make that choice
themselves and choose whether it's work
is what their investment so if you were
to do an experiment today I would say
think about what you what you're trying
to get it if you're looking for a simple
gene expression if you're looking for
alternate splicing maybe you can just do
an array and get that data if you want
to validate it yeah sure you once again
you can do quick and dirty experiment
because the razors are definitely
cheaper both in cost as well as time you
can do your different time points fixed
it you know this is the same argument
one made ten years ago with qpcr inori's
so you can do qpcr selection fig.5
figure a time points do the more
expensive microarray see if you can use
the microwave do your initial analysis
and then go back and do it like you do
extensive deep sequencing or you could
do the deep if you've done the deep
sequencing in you is microwaves to
validate because we'll still be a much
more high-throughput experiment than
doing it by qpcr so i hope i was able to
convince you that you know you can make
that choice between an array arrays are
not extinct and you can choose your race
over RNA seek or in conjunction with or
anything i would also like a like
introduce it to my next speaker now dr.
crookman fuller from Indiana University
who has applied these questions to her
own research and without much ado let me
pass it on to issue hi is dr. cheaters
said he summarized their technical
aspects and advantages and disadvantages
for each technique and my talk will
focus on Riley chose the human
transcriptome array technology and
you'll see the application that you
chose for my research so it seems that
our
music is superior to correlational
microarrays due to its a deep sequencing
capacity of the whole transcriptome so
lever arm if you look at the depth
coverage as dr. Jeter said there may be
some limitations so I nasik is good with
normal transcripts detection of more or
non-coding RNAs alternative splicing all
over listed here and obviously if you
want some a global approach like you
want to do you don't want to know the
what kind of genome is out there in your
genome but in this now we know that
human transcriptome is actually very
much well developed and then so there
are new ways of tackling to do a whole
transcriptome sequencing for example the
RNA sequencing may not be are great if
you think that if you have seen Eric dr.
tutors presentation that the debt is
very important indeed our biomedical
science most of the ironies that we are
doing actually around three million or
six million reads per sample which will
never ever did about 100 in that point
it's critical that we are missing a lot
of data that we thought we get from
underneath sequencing if we are not in
particular if you increase the depth
else occurs in being cost is getting
high and think about the clinical
samples and you have usually reach the
statistical significance that's
definitely loses its practicality and
another thing is only seek may not give
with this depth all these targeted
approaches for example you will get
transcripts and in particular I would
like to emphasize that link rnase
learning mode coding rnase they are
lower have more expression compared to
the protein coding genes and you may not
get the HTV on expression with an
atomistic with a lower debt so in that
sense I would think that the next gen or
micro arrays you can call that they
provide us multiple options you can use
a link on a micro array you can use an
mi RNA or as dr. Jeter mentioned the
human transcriptome arrays are really is
a a adaptation of the macro and I
technology it's not like the
conventional microarray technology
because it provides us older the whole
transcriptome analysis besides this I
also would like to pre information that
these next-gen micro arrays are not only
available for the transcriptome
profiling like the HDA analysis or other
analysis like copy number slips analysis
you can even use nowadays for FFPE
samples anka scan available from other
metrics for copy number somatic
mutations and other applications you can
not go too early and so on but my talk
will focus on especially human
transcriptome array analysis and I would
like to emphasize why we chose this
technology instead of our music in our
research so the main determinant was as
you can see here the availability of
multiple probes actually plant crops for
X own or not
anime and also for probes for supplies /
splice junction so this means are
actually a big change from the
conventional micron is that it was
impossible to retake the gene expression
however here the complete coverage of
probes really makes the analysis for
both low abundant or higher value
transcripts so this was the number one
reason the probe based strategy that we
wanted to use this in our research so
dr. Jeter also nation that so it is a
comprehensive transcriptome analysis so
therefore it has its providing more
probably if you think about the depth is
she literally see so you can detect and
you cover the human transcriptome at the
gene level transcript level XO level and
splice junction level and it's all drive
from this content available you can go
back and use these tools it is very much
integrated in the software so these are
the further features that features
besides its prophase you don't need to
worry about how much depth I need to go
the price is really affordable and i
think i would like to emphasize the most
under most another important point is
the the the bioinformatics is relatively
simple so most of the time on the bio
informatics takes so much time because
you have a huge data analysis with the
NAC and us specialized by a politician
but with this technology you just
download the arm the software and i'm a
molecular biology by training and then i
can easily use this technology anytime
and i go back to find okay about this
game means and go back to the software
and further analyzed
other downstream so it's very easy to
use for anybody and also less not time
consuming so my research is focused on
the identification of our normal targets
to overcome resistance to endocrine
therapies especially in estrogen
receptor breast cancer there are several
mechanisms helping so far are described
and this mechanism is mostly in
preclinical models some of them are
already shown or that is relevant in the
clinical setting but not all of them are
translated due to its difficulty to
between up a chemical and clinical
sampling comparisons so and if in
summary briefly there are usually three
categories tough first one it could be a
like alternative pathways that can
affect the estrogen receptor pathway and
then alters the sensitivity to therapies
or it's very known that estrogen is not
working alone through his coactivators
and co-repressors the in the balance of
this is very important to the
transcriptional activation of the
estrogen receptor and any of the
differences may lead imbalance and then
the resistance to therapies and recently
are paid because of the recent next-gen
technologies also there are genetic
aberrations have been found in estrogen
receptor like mutations or any other
rearrangements however there are still a
lot to answer as most of the sec from
the normal technologies that the are
signaling is not that simple there are
multiple layers of regulation
and we have to also understand how the
other regulatory mechanisms contributing
to the signaling in addition to the
protein coding genes so in that sense we
are interested to study the alternative
splicing and understand how the splicing
affects the sensitivity or resistance to
acquire resistance to endocrine therapy
so as you know that an alternative
splicing is very much detectable based
on these normal technologies and the
major aspect that we didn't know that
these events were not detectable to the
besides a domestic other technologies so
mainly if imperative splicing you look
at the antic XO level it can be an exon
skipped or included and exon can be
exclusively and regulated or an intro
can be retained you can see sub set of
the exone is supplied is skipped or
included or promoter or at the
three-point level so all of these
changes may make sense either alter or
not after the protein coding based on
the definitely where it's located so it
can be located in the very important
domains so then the function of the
protein is lost then you don't see any
function of this gene or protein and in
fact there's accumulating evidence
suggesting that alternative splicing is
important in cancer and it is also
described in terms of hallmarks of
cancer you can see here the most famous
sons bcl-x caspases you can see
resistance to sell that or other
home box p53 cd44 cd45 so all of them
there are some as number of genes
altered in antenna splicing and
affecting the phenotype of the tumor and
also I'm sorry it's little bit slow
small ideas but there are few examples
especially in breast cancer like the
bracha Valjean the breast cancer
susceptibility gene if only these exone
18 is skipped then you have a different
phenotype and tumor progression also the
others bcl-x short form or malformed
it's just because of an ex own
difference they can behave the cell can
behave like a pro apoptotic or
antiapoptotic so um based on this we
decided to look at the alternative
splicing events in endocrine resistance
cell models you have here two different
cell line models these are all about
mcf-7 a parental m-csf dried and made a
quiet resistance through per second
adding of tamoxifen or the second cell
line LCC 9 full restaurant we also
notice that although it's football
slight resistance we see a tablespoon
cross resistant so there are some
differences and then similarities
between these cell lines and on the
right hand side you see the arm the tag
which is transcriptome analysis console
but we did the isolated RNA and then we
sent earth underneath to alpha matrix
they performed hd8 analysis and send
back the data to us in protected ER teck
software which is easily downloadable as
dr. Jeter also mentioned and
we started looking at the gene level XO
level and alternative splicing level so
um this slide shows the volcano plot is
what gets readies for high up regulation
and then green is down regulation and
gray is the dreams that are not changed
so you can see on the overview of the
upregulated genes differential
expression of those jeans and if you
look at the tabular view you can see
that there are differences between these
two cell lines but also they are
overlapping so mainly and easily can get
the differential gene expression level
how many is coding how many is
upregulated or down-regulated in this
coating and also it also is for you to
non coding and harmony is upregulated or
downregulated so on we can also get the
information using the BG pad face what
kind of pathways are upregulated are
downregulated in our case we were happy
to see that and the receptor Metapod
fate is an altar which is actually the
main pathway and that is offered in
estrogen receptor signaling and then
converts the resistance to the endocrine
therapies so you can analyze that but um
the next one is actually the main
question that you would like to answer
was can we detect the alternative
splicing between these two different
condition sensitive and resistant cell
lines you can see a summary of the
differential alternative splicing events
and on the left hand side you see the
events either is a cassette exone you
take in thrown or any other listed
alternative pathways and then you can
see on this top the PSRs which is probe
selection regions
actually of the software the design of
the probes is not only one single X on
it depends on the length and exxon and
one PSR can continue 1x on or more EXO's
or based on the length of it and then
you can easily looking at the location
see where the change is happening here
in our data we first sorted based on the
adjusted FDR and then we look at the gym
change and also look at the different
alternative events you can see here the
cassettes axles are the majority of the
changes which is expected because the
mammalian genome mostly affected by the
change of the cassette exons the other
events are more or less rare so here you
can see a tabular view of using the
attack software and we sorted based on
the adjusted FTR p values and the top
alternative splicing event came up the
cd44 many of you know cd44 is already an
established marker for especially
stemness in breast cancer and other
cancers and if you look at the dr
temporary a little bit more detail you
can see on the left side you can see the
team changes and you see that I'll it
might have change at the gene level but
there is a huge change at the exone
level here especially on this column
splicing index tells you or the liberal
expression level at the exxon level
because it is actually after excluding
the gene levels how much change in the X
own expression happens and if the number
is high in the first name you see that
661 which means that plus it's included
and if you see a minus level it's
excluded so we were very happy to see
that all of these numbers are showing
that this X owns in this PSR region are
highly included in the resistant sell my
mother and the splicing events core is
also telling us that if it's its usual
021 the highly high number means that
it's highly happening and we chose or
you can see that between the two
resistance cell lines you can see the
overlapping PSRs or also there are the
stigma so we focused on the overlapping
bun and this slide shows the structural
view of an alternative splicing event
and just pour particular the bomb
diggity on one of the PSR that we focus
we can look at the intensity tracks the
level is changing between resistant and
the arm san scripts online and also it's
all shows your splicing track and these
exons included the red ones included in
the resistance cell line the same our
data in the candle by genomic V so i
took this is the most useful view i
would say because you can connect your
data with the other tools like an sample
so you can't figure out or visualize
that ok i'm looking here this X own but
does that mean is it what kind of
transcript I'm talking here so you can
easily see the transcripts already
existing looking at the end sample and
you can also connect to the UCSC browser
and make more extensive analysis so they
I think this is the mostly useful thing
because what we used to do before we
were opening all of these tools and then
looking back and forth back and forth
making a big difficulty but this
software also integrated the most
important links that you can take you
need for the
analysis of your data to translate from
genomic to the other transcript Nanak
and also donates so that actually is
interesting in a sense if I a little bit
summarize the structure of the cd44 cd44
gene consists of 21 exons and then the
first five x zone which is the exerciser
domain is standard so it is not changing
also the last five exons 15 to 19 is
also stand up it's not changing so if
you combine this this is called cd44
standard and you can see if you look at
the structure on the n-terminal is
different than the one that changes on
the other hand and the variable regions
which is the mid part from 5 and 14 can
change so this can be excluded or
included based on the tissue type based
on the condition you look or in our case
the HDA data revealed that we have
included the breast cancer specific
variants in our resistance cell line
model that means a lot because if you
look at the structure based on these
variants are only these extra loop stand
here makes a lot of difference in the
function of the cd44 and in exhibited
literature cd44 is well established for
the standards and especially cd44 + and
cd8 24 minus subpopulation but on the
other hand if you look further single 44
has been also implicated in tumor
suppression besides progression so we
don't know what it means we always think
that okay cd44 is a bad player and
unless targeted but on the other hand
it's very context
and whatever splice variant is present
in your tissue in your cell type so it
makes a big difference for example we
have also data that cd44 is can be a
good prognosis in er-positive breast
cancer so we couldn't understand okay
how come cd44 can be a good prognostic
marker well now we have tools to further
ask this question and look at it at the
splice variant level that maybe it's
because of we are having different
splice variants rather than just one
city for you for that everybody uses the
common antibody and seeing that whether
its expressive or not so I think as a
conclusion I would say that on the HDA
analysis provided us in a very
earthquake fail and very accurate way
how to look at the different layers of
the regulation transcript at the
transcriptome and we are happy to
continue with the data we have and
translate this into the chemical setting
thank you very much
well those are really truly excellent
presentations thank you very much for
bringing that information to us before
we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder of how
to reach us today questions can be sent
via the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window and
we'll try to get to as many questions as
we can so we have our first question and
our first question comes from IVA from
the University of Cambridge who asked
dr. shetar do you suggest validating
micro RNA data microarray data using
cdna generated in the array or actually
going back to the original RNA and
generating new cdna the goal that's used
for the microarrays if you're using
protocol like for example newgen
protocol which is P amplification you
make enough cdna and you need it part of
it to the next step going towards the
microarray so yes you can use that cdna
into qpcr but in most other protocols
you and whatever cdna you make is
typically used all the way through the
hybridization to the array so you would
have to go back to the starting material
can we make your cdna okay our next
question is for dr. Griffin Poehler and
the question comes from ola patty from
canon ministry who asked how frequent
are the environmentally modified genes
current transcripts identified and how
expensive are these sequencing programs
hi actually um this transcript can be
depends on the environmental we can say
so you have to have your exact controls
to determine that it is really because
of that condition or not and in terms of
your asking the each erase cost I
believe and I think compared they are
really usually not that expensive it's a
300 or something like that so really
achievable and the good thing is you
don't need to put too much replicates on
it it doesn't well great when next we
have ivan from uthsc who asked a
question of dr. Shekhar and he asked how
well to each platform to you with low
quality or degraded RNA dinner learning
is a big problem in your doing RNA
sequencing because you're going to you
are going to have smaller fragments with
sequencing however with the micro arrays
I mean a free actually has a sensation
plus kit which we've used very well with
suppose for example FFPE samples with
minimal or no loss and now in data so in
my opinion the race the sensation Plus
technology kit with the fe micro really
seems to perform very well sequencing
the diversion depends on the type of
sequencing you're doing it's a little
bit more trickier okay great our next
question we have a question for dr.
Kirkland polar from Ivan uthsc who asks
when you have a small amount of RNA you
need to first amplify how to each
platform perform with small amplified
samples I think this is a very good
question for the HTA you have also
people a level so if you have a small
RNA then I would recommend that you use
the picker version rather than the
regular version
great we have time for one more question
home and this is for dr. Sattar from
Camille who asks can you comment on the
cost difference between micrornas and
RNA seek I'm sorry micro arrays at RNA
seat so let me pushed out to the
previous question that talked about a
small amounts of RNA you know regardless
up with you know when you have small
amounts you have to amplify it right and
the more you amplify the more bias easy
and introduce so in a microarray
experiment all you're doing is you're
making cdna and then you're labeling
something hurting on the array and a
sequencing experiment you are amplifying
when you're adding adapter is doing more
PC are making now so there's a lot more
protocols that are involved which
include pcr and some form of the other
so in each of those steps you introduce
GC bias introduce amplification biases
so those are things that you need to
consider now in terms of the cost
difference between microwaves in RNA see
well if you haven't already if you have
a sequencing instrument in the lab and
you have a student in your lab who is
working all the time now they're very
comparable because labor is free if
you're paying for labor that's that's
more that's more expensive product then
all bets are off right so if you were to
deal an academic core facility where
labor is cheaper and a commercial entity
the arrays certainly are cheaper than
the RDC in my opinion okay now that is
if you do it do the experiment the way
we talked about if you're if you're
dealing with 10 million rates per sample
or five million tweets per sample are
you putting in a 50 samples in a lane
and sequencing it sure the cost would
come down but then you're sacrificing on
the other end with what output will be
the data that you can get from your
output
if you can find some splicing
information sure whether you fly finding
the real transcripts are you finding all
the splicing isoforms know so this is
where you need to be more careful and
you're making a comparison purely based
on pricing in the long run I mean arrays
are cheaper than right now the research
equal in sequencing if the amplification
kits and met the technology becomes more
cheaper think the sequencing might
become more directly comparable but but
given that option if people do more
sequencing the erase can become even
more cheaper because you can call more
updated counter it's going to be one
catching the other sort of the same way
as in my opinion I think a razor right
now where where qpcr technology used to
be that was really great um if there are
no more questions I would like to once
again thank our speakers for their
presentations and I would like to ask if
they have any final comments the only
thing I would say is I mean don't just
jump on the bandwagon and go gung-ho for
sequencing any experiment you do it
spend some time talking to people and
finding you know designing an experiment
properly a quick and dirty experiment
may not necessarily be cheap in the long
run because you might go chasing
something that is not true you have a
lot of false positives and false
negatives so in experimental design is
where you should you should spend the
most amount of time in designing an
experiment so make sure you have the
right number of replicates make sure you
you you know what you're asking you know
if my question is look for splicing then
you need to find out am I getting enough
data to answer that question regardless
of the technology right if I'm looking
for splicing and I use a gene estuary
I'm making the same mistake so those are
the things i would think about and you
know good luck on all your experiments
now based on experience I definitely
recommend to use the next-gen micro
arrays and then yes our mystic we have
also used it but in terms of efficiency
I would say for my own research we could
get a very accurate and valuable data
from those micro arrays and I would
definitely suggest the next generation
microarrays for because it is not the
ones that we think that the micro arrays
these are the ones that also provides at
hydrabad a whole transcriptome coverage
so I would definitely recommend based on
experience well once again I would like
to thank our speakers dr. sridhara
shitara and dr. younger people are today
as well as our sponsor after metrics for
making it possible for to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast we
available for on-demand viewing through
august of 2016 you will receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on lab routes comm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join us today thank you
again for logging in and participating
in today's broadcast see you again next
time goodbye